thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the careful boys we have with us our
guest Mr Anthony Lee don't do that what
that's my [__] you can't steal my [__] I
like introducing as a guest it feels
cool oh thank you Anthony you ever been
called after me I do get called Anthony
by some people that's a tight name you
like that name uh I'll let you know what
about me I have been called that by the
entire like Boy Scout Troop that I was a
part of and uh it's a little bit of PTSD
what's mean no well it's also my last
name is Lee so it's
it's like eat a bowl of noodles yeah a
cup of noodles yeah that's even it's
wordplay oh that's where it started
Vietnamese yeah and then we made some
noodles so [__] all y'all okay can you
bleep that thing no here's a very
popular question that I have heard asked
before
um and we're gonna have some varying
answers so it'll be good all right if
your parents are constantly fighting is
it wrong to tell them to get a divorce
um
I encourage my mom to get a divorce you
actually told her to yeah how did you
say that
um well it was
it made more sense in my situation
because he's already left the house oh
so he basically his
um last I guess the last agreement or
what they talked about is like you know
I think I need to
um go out move out and then like you
know
whatever like whatever [__] he told
her like I need to go out find myself
whatever I don't know what it was
exactly
and then I was like what are you doing
waiting for him oh we're pretty much
just this is the family and it's been
like two three years and I'm like we
don't need to keep this big
four three bedroom house
we can move into an apartment throw away
all his [__] get a divorce
you know if he's not giving you any
money like get child support
I think I was 14 at the time wow so I
was like smart guy yeah and I wanted to
move to Monterey Park because I thought
that like um my career and gang life
here might be a little bit better than
Gardena I was thinking about the future
you're right when you said that to her
was did it feel like an obvious answer
like it you didn't struggle with
admitting that that that's how you felt
did it feel very like oh yeah it's a
no-brainer you should totally leave him
no at this point I hated him so much
that like I wanted to like finalize like
so many things and then I think two
years after that I got this tattoo to
show my mom like hey like I'm a [__]
jitsukawa like I'm not his you know yeah
like this is how [__] serious I am
that's gangster but also I really wanted
a tattoo and I wanted like a cool way to
do it great excuse yeah [__] you Dad but
also joke's on me because my real
last name would have been Ito what do
you mean my grandma and my mom kept
jitsukawa which is my mom's father's
name right but they had a divorce and I
didn't know that my grandma never
changed her name after divorce but my
grandma's last name is Ito so I was like
I want to honor grandma and I'm like
that's her name jitsukawa but no one
told me they had a divorce wow so when
you showed your mom the tattoo she went
would you rather like wrong last name or
like fear everyone
[Laughter]
name's kind of cool right it's cooler
than Ito because Ito is pretty common it
is so when I got it
um I mean I I wanted to tell my mom like
let's be jitsukawas because you're
carrying his name divorce him let's both
like she changed her name too she
changed her name back well no now she
has a uh she actually kept I think she
kept it and she remarried so it's like a
combination thingy but it's very modern
for women her age to like have keep her
last name plus that
um yeah so I uh but she was like my
relationship with my father was amazing
so she's like it's cool like it's still
our family so I was like okay
anybody else think it's right or wrong
to suggest that to your parents I didn't
have a choice so my parents they just
got divorced when I was six
so I didn't really have a choice
um they were fighting like crazy but it
was also I was also a young age where I
don't remember like I remember a couple
of the really really big ones
like where my dad storms out of the
house or he like threw an Apple at the
uh window and it shattered and I
remember like me being [__] scared
I'm like oh [__] what the [__] going
on you know because I'm like five or six
five or six I can only imagine like um
because I could imagine if I like threw
something at a window and it cracked but
how tight it would feel you know oh yeah
so like I think obviously as a kid you
want them to stay together but also
that's also like having a child's mind
where 100 yeah yeah you're just like oh
I can't just just be like the way it is
on TV or whatever you know not knowing
that maybe they might not have been a
good match or they're really toxic for
each other or whatever
so yeah it's hard to say
but knowing how the story played out in
my in my life where my Dad tried to
rekindle everything and it's exactly the
way that I thought it was gonna be
where like my my dad's complained about
my Mom and Mom's complaining about my
dad on my [__] news was gonna happen
um I think it was actually good that
they separated for those like 20 30
years because at least we're able to
kind of just focus on themselves and not
have this like like
toxic like tumultuous relationship that
they have to deal with each other you
know are all your parents together Yes
mine are yeah mine are technically
together but they're not like they
shouldn't they're separated oh my dad
doesn't even live in the area so they're
like not divorced on paper but they live
like they're separated right yeah yeah
and I feel like that's the best thing to
do and it was it wasn't for taxes yeah
probably uh and just for like you know
so that way my mom can still get taken
care of and like he still you know helps
my mom with stuff too but it's at a
point where it was um like growing up we
always would see them like fighting all
the time and they probably didn't have
the best model for a relationship you
know like I'd always hear from those
weirdo I would always hear I would
always hear like you know my my mom
not complain but just like vent to us
about like Dad growing up right well why
did she protect you from that she just
complained about him I think she just
didn't know how to handle it like she
just didn't know like she was kind of on
an island and all she really had were
her kids you know because she came all
the way from a different country you
know so we were and I think she was just
like in a not in the best state of mind
like it just wasn't really she was
unhappy with a lot of things
[Music]
um and my dad was just kind of like
I think
they just didn't know how to communicate
with each other you know so seeing how
they grew seeing that growing up I was
always just like huh my I would hear
other stories about my other buddies
parents and kind of see how they
interact and I was like oh that's not
like my parents you know and then as I
got older I realized like yeah they
probably shouldn't be together
especially once I started entering my
own relationship with uh with my lady
and obviously you know our relationship
wasn't like
I just remembered going into our
relationship like oh yeah we should
communicate with each other and like
tell us tell each other how we feel
about things you know so we do learn huh
yeah just like through through just
model of my parents
um and then as I got older I started to
realize here for my dad his point of
view of what he thought of my mom and
vice versa so who's the more right one
um I think they're both wrong equally in
a lot of ways interesting I think you
know if they just were a little bit more
empathetic to each other and kind of saw
each other's side a little bit more they
probably could have met a common ground
but it's just a lack of communication
over the years I think it was just like
the damage was done right the resentment
was done and it's to the point where I'm
like I don't know if you guys have come
back from this so as they got older and
I would see them once they separated how
much happier they were without each
other
um and how much they could kind of live
their life
without each other and I go yeah this is
probably the best thing they can do so
as an adult in my later years I'm like
especially more recently I'm like
yeah this is probably the best choice
and even when they're together
especially recently I was like dude this
is there's no way no way absolutely no
way like it's just and when I found out
how they got together in the first place
I was like oh you guys kind of did rush
into it and I don't think it's
necessarily their fault it's just more
of like
just the sign of the times yeah of like
the pressure of getting married how do
they rush into it well it's like they
didn't really know each other that long
and my dad is kind of one of those guys
that
I don't want to say he's impulsive but
he's just Fool's rushed in let's do this
let's go well maybe they're in love at
the moment for sure but even then my mom
was hesitant at the time and I think my
mom is a little probably more cautious
naturally yeah and a little bit more
like reserved as far as like how she
wants to move forward with things and my
dad has always been like yeah let's do
this is a good idea let's go he's always
kind of like he's always been like that
as far as personalities was so seeing
how my mama told me that when he asked
her to marry
to get married she was like
um I don't know let me think about it
I think she and then it was more of like
there was like other factors that came
into play and then when she came to the
states
the early issues that they had with each
other were being solved by from this one
from my mom's point of view of her being
like sent back home or like like I don't
know how to deal with this distance you
go do this I'll go over here so yeah
it's and I think over time it just was
not the best way to go about it but you
know it's just that's I guess the the
cost of when you
rush into a situation or you learn on
the go and you're not really
talking certain things out but that's
just part of it I guess you know yeah
would you encourage them to get a
divorce I don't know or do you think
papers and [__] honestly like I don't
know if it's in the right place because
I think there's
they have valid reasons to want
a divorce and then battle reasons to not
want to divorce oh wow I I think it's at
a place now where it's like okay well if
my dad is willing to be like I'm out of
here I'll just you do you live your life
all of my life over here and I'll just
do my thing and if he's okay with doing
that and my mom was okay with doing that
and they kind of did agree on that for
the most part without like kind of
talking which is kind of crazy but I
think it's just
yeah that's probably the best way for
now I don't know down the line but that
also means it's salvageable yeah it
could be and that's the other thing too
is like maybe they can't come together
later in their life but it's um they're
just so much resent resentment maybe
they both can take some better help
and honestly that's probably what they
need counseling couple have they ever
gone to therapy together no I don't
think so do Asian parents even do that
no I think you think it's like uh
they're gonna go there but like why are
you not a real doctor
see that's the thing too man
like that's the thing like my dad is
pretty Americanized right like he's when
you hear him talk people think he's like
a white dude or a black dude on the
phone like or a black yeah it's either
or it's interesting so he's just a
southern man yeah yeah but but as far as
like
I don't know he's I think they're just
both kind of stubborn you know what I
mean and it's just um
make a ride yeah I think pride is a
thing right just
it's yeah it's tough man it's hard to
navigate that stuff because I don't know
what the right thing to kind of say or
do is but I just try to
when they're talking about each other I
try to just say okay let's try to like
be empathetic trying to listen easy yeah
like just try to hear him out a little
bit try not to you know or I just try to
give them opposing views like what if
you look at the situation this way like
you know but that's probably the only
thing I can offer you never say shut up
up no I try not to I wish no but even
then it's just like it's just hard it's
just hard because I understand where
they're all coming from that's nice you
just gotta like try to I don't maybe be
Peacemaker is not the right thing to do
but it's it's what I think is right in
the situation at least yeah I could also
Imagine like based off of you know what
BART was saying too especially I
remember my my parents um they would
fight from time to time but it's not
like my dad would never put hands on my
mom or anything so never like escalated
anywhere but I do remember sometimes my
Mom would make weird ass like comments
in her bitterness and just be like me
and your dad are fighting and we might
get a divorce is that what you want you
know just like say stuff like that which
is like putting it on you just emotional
you know what I mean and just maybe do
you want that I'm [__] up and that's
what she's saying as like oh it's just
bleeding out you know what I'm saying oh
wow but I do remember at that time not
being able to comprehend at all what the
[__] you're talking I've never been in a
relationship with my life I'm a child
like how can I weigh in on this yeah was
this at the laundromat yeah it was at
the dry cleaner damn drama cleaners as
long yeah it's very different
um but you know it's it's one of those
things where uh
like I could maybe
see that you know if you were a child
and your parents were in an abusive
relationship and you wouldn't have to
understand things like romance
understand like hey you should get a
divorce like this is not good for you
this is like unhealthy in a number of
ways but like you know if it's an
emotional thing and there's complexities
like as a kid
there is a part of you that feels like
it's not really your place because you
don't [__] get it yeah yeah you don't
know half of what's going on maybe when
you become an adult like you know after
a bar you know like had his own kid and
he could put things after like 20 30
years together it's like no you
shouldn't do this I think this is going
to be wrong because you have like come
to an understanding you've been in
relationships you're married yourself
and you understand concepts of marriage
you understand like what it could mean
because you have a child like there's
yeah there's like wisdom and experience
there then maybe you could have a
certain type of Vote or or say so to
speak or wisdom but uh even hearing Nick
talk about the complexity of his family
it's like oh man like yeah that's got to
be hard there's got to be so many
factors and things that are like so
complicated you know divorce doesn't
necessarily like solve everything no
there's a whole new set of problems yeah
especially if the the individuals don't
have like uh their eyes set on a
particular future whether it's like
finding new romance and a relationship
or or certain type of like clear freedom
and boundaries or even if you wanted
that but you felt a guilt because of
like the family you created and the
children you know what I'm saying like
there's a whole set of things that I
have I have no wisdom in that it would
be difficult to speak about you know
that I feel like kids just want to be
like
why can't we just be like happy and [__]
yeah I just want to be a kid like let's
go to Disneyland and play together you
know what's crazy about my parents um
for the longest time growing up they
used to fight a lot and I used to always
tell my mom like oh dude you got a
divorce and you gotta divorce them
because I could see why that she doesn't
want to be with him
and this this is like his second wife
too and oh he's had he's already like
yeah strike two yeah and so growing up I
was like dude why are they still
together you know and I didn't get why I
don't understand and and my mom would
always cry and like tell me about oh are
you not that tight with your death I'm
actually really close to my dad but but
the crazy thing you can still see his
[__] or something oh it's his fault
for what reason they were fighting it's
pretty complex because he was a great
father but a terrible husband like in
the beginning yeah up there I guess when
they had us like it was super stressful
whatever so I can see why they would
argue about stuff and
over the years I was like I never
understood why my mom stayed with my dad
you're like it kind of actually ended up
being like a happy ending and I feel
kind of lucky that my mom decided to
stay with him because what ended up
happening was she basically forgave him
uh did for everything that he's ever
done for her and then from there on like
somehow
um I just noticed their relationship
change over time like you wouldn't think
people would change but if I saw I saw
them change go from like crazy like you
know not super violent but like crazy
arguments to like slowly trying to
understand each other and then
um even to this day now like I live with
both of them and dude they're like super
chill wow wow my dad's completely
changed person my mom's like way more
understanding and I was like holy [__]
I'm kind of glad they didn't get a
divorce even though at the time I felt
like that was the right thing but her
staying with him at actually ended up
being the right thing in the end but you
never hear about that though because
most people go divorce is the right
thing if you guys are arguing or
whatever but then you never know what's
gonna happen if you actually stay to the
end yeah that's true you know what's a
weird feeling about that too
um obviously when I was like uh
still living with my parents there would
definitely be times where I think like
my parents [__] crazy you know what I
mean like my dad's just always angry
[__] Asian dad never [__] gives
any type of like emotion whatever you
know what I mean my mom is just like
cuckoo you know and then it's like
same thing I'm like dude they're Never
Gonna Change they're like this type of
parents to me yeah and then I get out of
the house and then I mature or something
like that or maybe they change or after
my mom's gone through menopause or
something there is a change you know
what I mean the relationship's different
yeah yeah and then I started thinking of
myself I'm like man was I the problem
you know what I mean like be honest not
that you were the exact problem but I
think like people's patience has a
certain bandwidth yeah so if they got
work stress they got relationship stress
now they got kid stress they're probably
just taking [__] out everywhere yeah the
minute like kids are older or whatever
they're like oh [__] like I'm trying to
breathe and maybe that helped out do you
know what I think about all the time too
is like nowadays in our like Generations
you hear so much like people talking
about mental health talking about how to
be conscious yeah being mindful like
like you hear all these these phrases
that you didn't really hear about
growing up no not at all but then you
think about like the resources that we
have now when it comes like how open
therapy is and how open counseling is
and all these Concepts that are being
talked about in these these spaces it's
like our parents had none of that [__]
that's why some of them stay stupid and
stubborn yeah if they don't have the
tools to break out of that mindset but
it but it's crazy because like talking
about what can was like picking back off
that like I am starting to see like
little pockets of my parents changing in
ways that I never thought would be
possible you know like for instance my
dad dude like his [__] road rage
would be crazy to the point where I was
like this [__] is gonna get shot
one day like the way what do you do oh
bro just [__] anything you can think
of like being on people's bumpers like
just crazy [__] to the point where like
he's actually got beaten up in front of
my sisters when they were like little
kids yeah crazy my sister's not a funny
story but like I've seen my dad flip out
like chase people down like just just
wild out bro like just crazy [__] but
then now I see him as an adult like yeah
man you know I'm not as an adult but as
an older man like him driving slow like
like that's that I'm like oh my god like
people games change
how drastic it was like the contrast of
how this [__] would drive and I
Dro I drove in the car with him recently
and I was like oh my God who the [__] is
this dude he's all like perfectly
driving and he's like
doing hand signals when he goes oh [__]
nah dude I think him driving in Taiwan
for a while kind of changed how he like
does things because he's like man like
and he was telling me that like I think
an incident happened in Taiwan and I
think it really scared him because he
got beat up I think I think I forgot
what the detail was but it wasn't that
he got beat up but he was close to being
like like threatened and he was like all
right I gotta like and chill out like he
he messed with the wrong guy and it was
it was the United bamboos no I think I
think it was something like gangster
types and then they busted out a machete
and say you wanna [__] today
oh [__] man bring it on sound guy
let me have my boot mic oh a man we can
huh that's why I think you shouldn't
have as a guy you shouldn't have kids
until you get to that stage of your
manliness yeah but what if I want to
leave it inside can what if I want to
leave it inside man I want to feel what
that feels like
that's not oh that's the dilemma I like
that you're asking can what should I do
can't cream pie I mean I'm really happy
that like me and Jill plant and I know a
lot of our parents didn't really plan
they're just like just [__] kind of
they're just horny yeah there's hornies
that have kids I'm happy that we planned
the way we wanted to have kids like
where we wanted to be mentally where we
want to be financially and all that so
like now like
um Taiko will like ask Mom about
something doesn't get the answer he
wants like he'll come to me oh can I
have whatever I'm like me and your mom
on the same team dude you know and so
like he'll he'll never ever see us fight
and he'll know that we're on the same
team and that we will never vent about
the other person in front of him yeah
that's that's so [__] up that's super
important yeah yeah definitely
I'm gonna do the opposite of those
things
your mom's a [__]